[Music]
and where are they now news Dustin
Diamond screech man you can get his
dildo if you like it's molded don't look
it up don't look it up he's in this
screaming pickles or something not he's
stabbing I do it screaming what he's
like doing time right now yeah we should
just move on don't look it up you guys
asked well you have to tell me I stabbed
a dude at the bar dude screech did why
was someone picking on him like a horse
they were full on shame to do in the
world
oh I don't know probably not but I know
he's doing you're doing time yep
submitted by dip dem chips I could be a
VIPs
maybe or just a little bit means what
chips chips these 10 former celebrities
now have regular jobs celebrities like a
Starbucks barista or like like an
accountant like they went to school and
have like a regular like a bachelor's
degree job I feel like for a lot of
these they always stretch the word
celebrity about as far as you could
stress you know like Jon Gosselin is not
a celebrity he will be honest as a
guarantee
Jon and Kate Plus 8 it's all reality TV
people right others um yes how many
seasons did they get well here I'll show
you guys the first one so the first one
is even sugar this is like one of those
this is a [ __ ] thing though Bowl see
he still makes a lot he makes a [ __ ] ton
of money because my friend just worked
on a couple of movies oh yeah it doesn't
mean he doesn't have a regular job oh
you know what though he does that for
fun yeah exactly he does that's what I
said I would does it for bragging rights
yes the US legal is [ __ ] ridiculous
though he's insane he's crazy like he
really really thinks that he is this
action star but then like everyone knows
we're at this point where we were a lot
smarter when it comes to martial arts we
know what works what doesn't work and
all this stuff but he's still stuck in
the 80s and then so my agent was telling
me he saw him on a shoot and he brought
this tie very young hooker to the shoot
and that was like his servant throughout
the whole time and they're like this
guys [ __ ] crazy
yeah just look up what's it called
Steven Seagal stories on YouTube and
you'll crack up and rest there's that
one story where gene LeBell the the judo
guy choked him out and and made him crap
his pants I heard that I heard that one
yeah those Steven Seagal shirt I [ __ ]
love suza call first of all because I
think because he lives the realest life
ever you know saying he doesn't he
doesn't kiss and give a [ __ ] and he
married Kelly LeBrock and like destroyed
her at her height yeah we're talking
like weird science Kelly LeBrock he
[ __ ] that up and put like four kids in
her whatever like he was beating that up
right and like that's a pimp status move
I think oh and then also he was an
Aikido legend google it it's all over
YouTube you can see him kicking all
hands at assets crazy during
demonstrations
oh no and he says that he says that he
was the in CIA and special optionals
[ __ ] right and my favorite thing is on
this show lawman he's like showing the
Louisiana PD or whatever like some moves
and like you can tell they just think
it's cool it seems the gauls there and
he's like he's like okay take out a gun
on me you think so what I'm gonna do is
like see what I'm doing here and we're
all just like what you're doing with it
but he's doing it so deliberately that
you're like he's an expert sure yeah
and all these guys are going yeah so he
is deputy chief in Louisiana so he is
known he's an actor in case you guys
don't know yeah but he's still loaded
he's still making movies and that's just
for his oh he's like an honorary cop yes
he's an honor it like Shaq was Shaq was
an honor yeah he was honorary sheriff's
or some [ __ ] like that
he got it taken away though because of
his public statements and how funny is
how I call it how funny he is he says he
says to do this [ __ ] all the time dude
but he says I'm is something insensitive
and he got taken away
but I call it hilarious mm-hmm I think
the stupid [ __ ] he ever said was Shazam
[Laughter]
you Thomas Sandman yeah that Mandela
long yeah I thought it wasn't that so
did we all did didn't Kareem
abdul-jabbar play no he'd be the biggest
genie on earth well actually Scheck no
what am I talking about
continue the number two on his list is
Jonathan Bennett he is now an indoor
cycling instructor in LA he's known for
Mean Girls
he's Aaron Samuels oh oh so you just
cycling instruction yeah and I browse
just to point out that this list is a
little dated so they may not be doing
all the stuff that we're talking about
today so I mean doing one film doesn't
make them a celebrity so they might be
in between jobs because he's film he
could still be able he also can be
prepared for a role as a spin instructor
or something like that yeah number three
is Nikki Blonsky
she is now a part-time hairstylist she
still auditions she was known for
hairspray okay that's interesting that
was like recently right she blew through
that money quick but that was it was
like within ten years was it yeah it was
like
my bad yeah she uh she's don't sorry
she's still going on dishes he's still
working that's my point
number four on the list true a lot of
people think once you do like one movie
that you've made it
that's like you made a man like every
actor you see on the screen they walked
away with a million dollars like no it
doesn't happen like that if they did try
I would [ __ ] no dude even Val
Kilmer's like on reddit turns to
autographs and [ __ ] I was a song that is
it's pretty crazy yeah he made millions
yeah number four is Peter Ostrom he's
known for Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory he's now a veterinarian in New
York Willy Wonka a Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory he's good kid he looks
like he's still living in that era yeah
so he's a cattle farmer not to judge his
life but he [ __ ] peaked early but the
gut sucks you know I'm saying it's not
stoop eek that early and like have such
a [ __ ] thing where you're a legend
for it and then it's just like after
that swing you still play on the TV
every Christmas yeah Ralphie in them
Christmas Story yeah you gotta go that
Justin Bieber out like he started off
famous and then he just got more famous
yeah and then you become infamous we're
doing [ __ ] I think he made like what 90
mil this year some like yeah desperado
that's for a suppose this receipt yeah
collaboration he did with the Bieber did
that yeah you mean ninety million this
mean you mean like 90 million so he just
canceled this huge tour - and that's
prior to him canceling that tour that he
or him in that night a party just found
out he made 90 million apparently he's
like this hardcore Christian you know
hardcore Christian oh that's a real job
which one was it
I know some funny insider name you know
what's crazy he doesn't want to admit
this but he's a youtuber yeah I remember
I remember yep I was going through my
old sound Bank I mean a music video Bank
yeah I would look at and I'm like wait
that's baby Justin Bieber yeah I
remember his list of musicians that he
looked up to fashion
night yeah wait he took that [ __ ] off oh
really
yeah that's too bad he took it off
number five on the list is Tony Danza so
he was no yours who's your loss
well he's a teacher now who's the boss
it's a lot of shows to get religious man
he [ __ ] blew that I think high school
English teacher in Pennsylvania real
it's a [ __ ] family he was trying to
start a reality show around him being an
English teacher English teacher so you
think he's doing it for the money
because I know back in a day people just
blew through that money and the
contracts were [ __ ] up or like you
went up your nose at the time I mean for
sure in those days they were all doing
yeah number six on the list is Robert
Van Winkle Oh
aka vanilla yep no well he's still
balling yeah he's known for being a
rapper TV shows and you even published a
book on real estate and now he's a real
estate investor I think he makes more
money now that he did back then that's
insane have you seen that ridiculous
show that he has on the TV he did a show
on yeah yeah that's the one I'm talking
about his like house flipping show it's
really bad yeah that was a recent
picture in the recent yeah oh that sucks
I like this flat top and all that stuff
the music video from the number seven on
the list is dylan sprouse he's known for
a sweet life oh yeah but that he has
money he just wanted to normalize his
life yeah so you took a six-year hiatus
he hosts at a restaurant
Wow you click on a lot of [ __ ] on the
Internet
you're the NY NYU student he graduated
back in 2015 he studied video game
design and yet she was the restaurant
coach he's a restaurateur corner - Nikki
dish host my dad I never watched that
show while he's gonna get him out he was
also in Big Daddy he was the kid yeah oh
you got a black eye maybe that's a show
are you just tired tired tired eyes yeah
please a waiter uh-huh like when do
people that greet you like a greeter
that seat you at the people that you
blow by and ignore that's not even as
good as the hot wait no it's not you
don't get tips or anything it's their
job what is money goal no I mean you
know he still has money supposedly he
still has money he said he just wanted
to normalize this life started acting
again this year yeah it's like well look
what happened to you bro I don't know
talk to my Millions [ __ ] yeah number
eight is Ariana Richards known for
Jurassic Park shows a girl named Lex in
Jurassic Park gotta see a picture she's
now an artist that's not a regular job
she's like there's a little girl yeah
that's not a regular job that's still
like from a creator to a Christian I
agree get the [ __ ] out if she was like
an artist at the like the theme park
doing those big characters like big
context matter it has to seem brutal it
has to seem soul-crushing we agree
that's what a real job I know Johnny
Dawson's working at Chili's dude I know
he is I saw he's working at [ __ ]
Hrothgar and it's really good
the restaurants keep on getting worse
and not that there's anything wrong with
working there but it's that it's where
he came from making a million episode
and also you don't want to work there
for cheese so John got he probably saw
something alimony and said thanks on the
list yeah so he was working as a waiter
at a pub he's also he also deejays and
yeah there was this thing last year
where he was saying that he was gonna
become a male stripper and have his
debut and I let him
city on April 1st people he just wanted
his name back in the news exactly he
even poses on me like so I'm John
Gosling I broke the internet I mean
that's what's what's what's terrible
about it is that it's a bad joke because
it seems pretty plausible yeah it's so
sad it's so sad that this is like the
highlight of their life and they want to
stay relevant they're like 12 or
something like 13 or no the old disk so
you know I have two twins before the
yeah so the twins are now 16 and the
[Music]
Octomom still right talked about versus
[ __ ] do you border what she did porn and
she's good now no that's not sure that's
not true that's like the the Teen Mom
Farrah whatever her she turned it to a
four star oh yeah she's a point she's
ball on it she's bond and then she
invests her money he does other stuff
too now I saw her yeah I'm somewhere
online I heard she's like a straight
port Stern rcent yeah yeah she's
probably done some but I don't think
that's what she does
all the time she does that for fun I
want a reality TV show and then do porn
after dude you know who got it who got a
job though [ __ ] Jessica I look at
that real money dude okay well Jessica
Alba took her took her money here and
then made it yeah that [ __ ] is insane
it's like one of Paltrow she did the
same [ __ ] but on that smaller scale then
that's so smart the last person on our
list is Kirk Cameron what he's known
growing pains he's in they still make
some movies they're just Christian
movies DJ's cousin do I love his Miami
Vice outfit I wear blazer over a t-shirt
nice to watch me too
he was a he know in real life he's DJ's
brother yeah yeah in the show he played
her cousin the episode what had happened
was she came right and they grew up and
then they weren't really kicking it like
they used to because now he's too old
for her and she got really upset and
then she was acting like a little [ __ ]
I didn't even know she had a cousin in
the show yeah
it was it was Kirk Cameron he played
that part yes in which Owen in a full
house is he coming back for the noon I
have no idea
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]